figured I'd start the podcast on my own
first thing I want to say is I'll be at
Zanies
I think we're already almost sold out so
I think there are tickets left for the
two early shows Friday Saturday get your
tickets then of course I'm in Cleveland
January 30 31 and Feb 1 at hilarities
I'll be at the West Palm improv February
14 15 and 16 for Valentine's Day weekend
let's see West Palm Beach improv get
ready and be ready yeah if you're gonna
start the podcast alone just because
Brendan set a meeting and I'm between
shots I probably got a little make-up on
my face which makes me look fantastic my
hair is dusted and my scalp is painted
Ricky Gervais exposing Hollywood with
what a star in Netflix is bird box a
movie where people survive by acting
like they don't see a thing sort of like
working for Harvey Weinstein finally I'd
like to thank Harvey Weinstein ah The
Punisher that's his nickname The
Punisher yes Harvey
I keep thinking you're in public people
SDIO Dilys yeah this is a video a
compilation of every Hollywood star and
director thing the thing about is this
he was a [ __ ] [ __ ] right and a
liar and a [ __ ] but he was
phenomenal at his job like he just knew
great movies knew what was gonna work
nobody better nobody better and I love
that Holly was being exposed cuz they're
so [ __ ] hypocritical and fickle and
nobody gives a [ __ ] in Hollywood nobody
really cares about anything in Hollywood
other than making money and keeping the
Machine going if you're an actor you
have to toe the line you will not work
if you're an actor you are you rely on
so many other moving parts you rely on
50 other people mainly there are
decision makers you have to keep happy
and if you piss off the wrong people you
ain't working anymore
and there are just too many people like
me waiting in the wings so it turns you
into a yes-man whether you know it even
if you're a good person it's really hard
not to be until you get some power but
very and then that's why when the stars
get real power they turn in they're like
[ __ ] this I don't want to do this
anymore
but for the most part you got a toe the
line and even when you're a huge star
Hollywood the brass that you don't see
they can just decide you're difficult
like Russell Crowe and be like hey you
take a seat forever or for a long time
so it's a town full of it just turns you
into a coward in my opinion it cracks me
up everybody knew what he was about
everybody [ __ ] knew but you know what
he was really good and if you were in a
movie there was a chance it was gonna be
huge
can you go on to another awesome job and
he made great [ __ ] movies here's the
other side of the coin you can meet
serial killers you can meet pieces of
[ __ ] and if they don't want something
from you if you're not one of the people
they enjoy victimizing they can seem
like really nice cool people that's the
crazy thing about this complicated ape
that is human so it's pretty fascinating
and so had 20/20 hindsight is always
20/20 but I get a kick out of this [ __ ]
did you ever know him or meet him I
never met him my father had to deal with
him because I
father was working for our financial
institution so my dad had one-on-one
time with him a lot of one-on-one time
and my friend who's a director and a
very big director called my father
in fact Harvey who called my dad because
they needed money from the institution
and he said I understand your son is an
actor in Hollywood oh oh he goes how
what a coincidence of something like
that it's all he said my friend is a
director said before that it's my father
whatever you do do not tell
do not tell Harvey that your son is an
actor because if he wants something from
you and you don't give it and he decides
maybe that that's a personal thing or
whatever he can ruin his career with a
phone call 100% true now I'm a comic and
so it would have been harder but there's
no doubt that guy could and did ruin
people with phone calls with one phone
call everybody was terrified of him cuz
he's a piece of [ __ ] he's a bad guy and
now has been exposed here's what's crazy
about Hollywood I would not be surprised
if he works his way back if he's found
if he's acquitted of all these [ __ ]
charges I wouldn't be surprised if
somehow because he's so good and people
value as his artistic opinion so heavily
I wouldn't be he'll start in the shadows
he still got all his money I mean a lot
of his money anyway
I don't know what he I don't is XY
everything is dating Adrien Brody right
now I don't know if I'm supposed to know
that but I think it's hilarious and I
happen to know the guys still getting
laid yeah he's on about yeah well the
other thing that people don't realize is
that this guy was a piece-of-shit rapist
and a bad guy but he was getting laid
there are a lot of women there are a lot
of women Hollywood that were that were
lining up to suck his dick for a favor
and I'm not talking about great
actresses although they had to dad told
a certain line but there's no doubt that
that there are women who are very hot
and who were actresses who slept with
him and got real
word for it there's no doubt what a
business Hollywood so funny that way we
used to always had these mandatory
sexual harassment meetings on any TV
show you were in that just went away
because you know people like what
meeting what are you talking about oh
you're gonna have a meeting now I'm have
to sit in the meeting and you're gonna
tell me that I'm I have to not harass
people go [ __ ] yourself anyway like
whenever I see Weinstein and him being a
producer and stuff like that I don't
know the details because you know a lot
of times people have connections and
money and they just tag producer on
their name well your max was a company
that that Weinstein Weinstein was was
they say and I've heard this from
reliable sources he could read a script
he could read five pages of script and
tell you if it was gonna be a hit or not
mm-hmm
I mean there's no question he was that
good and working for him was for many
people that deal with the devil and
worth it worth it and there are women I
would never say their names but there
are actresses that you would know that
that did did sleeve them yeah and were
rewarded and there were actresses that
didn't sleep with him and they got
destroyed Mira Sorvino is one of them I
don't know you know I don't have a lot
of proof on that but I believe it
wholeheartedly I really do
she was a smart talented Galman went to
Harvard I think so anyway he's got his
trials we'll see what happens I know a
trial or else I'll take that case all
day because there wasn't enough evidence
so I think he'll be acquitted but he's
still been disgraced and that's the
important thing
what a fall from what a Shakespearean
fall from grace to go from the King to
pariah do you know what he you know he
actually had a crisis meeting and
somebody suggested that he take all his
clothes off get himself in a cage and
invite the public to throw [ __ ] at him
what yeah he was trying to figure out
any way he could redeem himself and now
he's doubling down and saying stuff like
nah listen man I
the first guy to liberate women I was
the guy to put women and as directors
and actresses before anybody else
he said you [ __ ] yo-yo it's amazing
hold on what's it say there look at
those dudes next to him hard one sends
lawyers asked judge to recuse himself
fifty more potential jurors dismissed I
know because everybody knows about it
it's so interesting yeah yep what's
going on with you guys I don't know
what's going on oh you cat
nothing in particular just another day
just another day just another day
another day fantastic that's really
amazing yeah
I have in my house renovated right now
and what I like to do is I walk in and I
don't know anything about building mm-hm
and I look at it and I go like this I go
it looks good what kind of what are you
guys using on this and they'll say
something and then I go huh and I take a
second Mike and I fake analyze it just
so they think I know what I'm doing and
I go you let the wood breathe how much
longer we're gonna let the wood breathe
so it expands here is that I mean I
don't know if the temperature I do that
it's really good
did you see this um I'll show you right
now quick there's an article about you
on ksl which is like a Utah news station
I think yeah and it's uh it says have
you seen this dad have you seen this dad
sure is dramatic Utah Heritage kids
aren't talked about this last we did it
we did it before the show oh yeah you
don't say no oh well there I am can we
watch it yeah we watch it let's watch it
I think this is absolutely hilarious
now the mountains kids the mountains
what I had to tell a living
Utah Utah's what forge me from the boy
to the man I am today
these mountains could tell a tale kids
you would be amazed I don't expect you
to recognize what it just to make me I
gave birth to you I did give birth to
well I had a lot to do with giving birth
to you yes but you have taken on my
genes
yeah be honest being my children my
offspring
and I am a great and a great man I'm a
famous as you saw in the airport you
have Mike's son but you also have
Italian Irish blood in you know for me
as well yes but you should care because
as a man I understand but as a man these
mounds to tell my tale it would span an
epoch in its passage it
I understand you're young jeez this is
it went viral too high no point view how
many over two point four yeah million
views holy his mother god that's on
Twitter yeah god that's crazy that is
crazy yeah I you know those are those
things where you just I was just bored
and I was looking at the mountains and I
was and my ex my amanda was like hey hey
eight hole she didn't tell me this but I
heard she's like don't be videotaping
and driving but I had the phone I was
keeping my phone the phone was like
propped up so it was fun yeah
but um it was uh it was one of those
things where you just you just like I
was bored and I was like you know I'm
gonna pretend I'm a mountain man you
talk and how the mountains forged me and
of course after I was doing the video I
had a thousand other ways to do it that
was better but the magic was lost
that's the magic though you captured it
pretty well right yeah and with the
children the way you guys are going back
a four thousand they go nuts so father
as a man as a kid we don't care but as a
man my all but the only thing I can
offer my kids is is humor the only thing
I can frickin offer my kids
self-reliance and a sense of humor but I
don't know what else to do I mean I can
teach them but they never listen the
frustrating thing about having kids is
that you've lived I lived 52 [ __ ]
years I got some things to say they will
not listen hey I my daughter won't even
let me teach her about acting I can't
even help her on a [ __ ] audition
drives me nuts she's got a [ __ ]
audition for a play I'm like you know I
can die like the minute I even talk
about it I go you have an audition I
mean yeah I'm like are you [ __ ]
kidding
even Taekwondo they were saying Tiger
I'm a black belt like I won the
Nationals in Iowa let me teach you
you're kicking wrong teachers wrong dad
you don't know anything
yeah sure yeah they shut you the [ __ ]
down
it drives me crazy hey hey kids let me
give you some shortcuts how's that sound
let me let me shorten things up because
life's a kick in the nuts
here's my new things but I stole this
from my buddy Jeff Foley I look at them
and I go
I go I'm we have to go to practice we
have to go to tennis and they're like I
don't want to go I'm so tired I go I
know I'm so sorry I apologize for being
a pain in the ass and the reason I have
to be a pain in the ass the reason I
have to be a kick in the nuts is because
life is a much harder kick in the nuts
and a much bigger pain in the ass so I
apologize for that and that's what I do
and they can't stand it
sorry I have to take your iPad away from
you now I know it sucks but it's because
life is gonna take your iPad away from
you way longer than I am so I have to do
this for you and I'm sorry I'm sorry I
have to get you ready for the world
they hate me it changes though all right
once you reach a certain age though my
dad was this may I hope so has to that's
how I feel about my parents well I can
for granted for a long time that the
thing is that they see you get like they
see me get recognized and link in the
air that's also unusual for kids too
yes and they're starting to kind of put
that into perspective which is weird for
them but I have to make sure that they
don't think that's a thing because I
don't want them chasing that I'm not
impressed with Hollywood's kids I'm not
impressed with actor kids for the most
part actor kids or actor well if your
kids are if your father's I'm not famous
but I'm you know but but I'm famous
enough you know so that when you with
your kids kind of see that and I don't
know that that works out for it I don't
know why but I've not been very
impressed with a lot of the the
offspring of many of our our favorite
actors there's one in the current events
too there is yeah when we get there show
it to me no how do you wanna see it now
or should we wait we should probably
wait I never with her Brenda no where is
he I knew he was gonna be late that's
why I want to stress I have to be at
work that's okay it's all good I know
it's all good doing the fight companion
tomorrow what are you guys watching
I think classic Phi
I'm not sure yet Oh find out I'm excited
though and it's awesome
I'm excited Moo's all middle of the day
it'll be it'll be at three or so and I'm
wondering if I should bring some wine
just Johnny contently yeah stuff for
sure my Saturday I gotta send the Comedy
Store after that
so we'll say yeah you'll be in a good
mood happening and then you said good
wine
yeah how come you guys ever bring stuff
here like wine and two million to early
but I mean once in a while can't drink I
don't think Jenny wants to drink you
drink
well I enjoy like social drinking yeah
and also beer by myself really I used to
do it every night then I stopped how
much you drink two to three beers that's
actually a lot cuz they're stronger
beers too like 7% three beers I did for
a while what time do you start as soon
as we're done here really that's like
eight ish nice and then after that eat
and then knock out it's the best feeling
oh really so you eat late at night yeah
man I cannot [ __ ] do that if I eat
late at night pop pop out a nap and I'll
wake up sweaty with a fog why am i in a
sauna I dream about being in an oven if
I eat you want to kill me give me a
steak and luck in a bottle of wine and
see how I so good though oh dude I'll
die wait did it happen as you got older
or was yep always your day yeah that's
sure did as you get older your body
betrays you I got to do neck exercises I
have to do all kinds of things I have to
swirl my goddamn feet in the morning you
know what I'm so funny if I saw my
six-year-old runner cold right yep no no
stop moving stop working the old machine
the old machine get needs a little Lube
yeah always something wrong with you as
you get older and I'm in pretty good
shape yeah I've got a lot of energy but
yeah so I'm going down to San Diego this
thing called health nucleus
I'm gonna get myself a full bot it's
gonna be a five-hour [ __ ] physical
and if my testosterone is a tiny bit off
is it tiny bit off I'm gonna have
them [ __ ] hooked me up to a mountain a
mountain gorilla a silverback mountain
gorilla and a bull and I'm gonna get
their blood flowing through my blood and
that's what's gonna happen and I'm gonna
get thick you want to be thick huh I
don't know say this I know a guy who had
cancer he had melanoma stage two
melanoma is dancer on a skin really bad
and they peeled his skin like 10 layers
down he looks he's 60 he looks like he's
20 I was like damn you know how they
peel the skin they just they take they
they go layers down when you got
melanoma they take all of it down that's
crazy
layer by layer of cancer skin off how
did he make that much new skin though
surfer oh he was a surfer you fear for
his whole life yeah and then they just
they were like hey dude your face go get
your face checked out cuz you got things
I mean cut off his head ears oh my gosh
welcome but he looks totally normal you
would never know you would never so it's
kind of a good thing then cuz he looks
younger
I hope he's good I hope he's good man
you worry about that [ __ ]
it's no joke cuz once it gets in your
lymph nodes this is no good
yeah our bodies you know what the new
frontier of cancer treatment is 30 years
or whatever over 40 or 50 your body's a
conduit for information whoa I started
early I just have never done it I just
felt like going crazy
Hey
for the first time in my life I am a
customer of this company it happened a
long time hemes 66% of men start to lose
their hair by age 35 that would be Bryan
Callen dude and it's working of course
it's working
hey listen I did I did an online
everything I said it picks to a doctor
in five minutes I had my prescription it
was honest where I don't have to go to
the doctor and dude and yours is working
of course it it is working stop looking
up like that I've got a full head of
hair then I don't have to dust it
anymore and that's what they do they've
got finasteride they've got all kinds of
stuff if you got it wrecked-tile
dysfunction they got you on that too no
more awkward and
and doctor visits none of that answer a
few quick questions the doctor will
review and bam it's prescribed shows up
to your house let it grow with hymns
diving a 2020 here first right now you
guys get the first month free go to four
hens calm /fa TK that's four hams calm
/fa TK prescription inquires your online
consolation with physician who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate offer vowed only prescribe
three month minimum subscription
additional restrictions apply
see website for full details important
safety information murder that's four
hymns calm /fa TK big news everybody yep
it's finally happening this is the year
I'm straightening my bottom teeth my top
ones are fine but I'm straight my bottom
ones with candid clear aligners and you
guys can join the straight Club straight
teeth Club that is and if you're
anything like me and you're not happy
with your smile you're self-conscious in
your photos I'm not I just want my teeth
not to throw up gang signs they deliver
clear aligners directly to you and you
straighten your teeth for 65 percent
less than braces on like braces candy
clear aligners are comfortable they're
removable
they give you a little bit of a list not
a big deal Brian dealt with it is entire
life they're totally invisible that's
right no one's gonna know don't wear the
metal braces don't be that guy plus you
never have to step foot in a doctor's
office or a waiting room your treatments
prescribed remotely by a licensed
orthodontist and they deliver everything
you need right to your door alright look
ahead to a wedding season maybe a
special event
maybe you got a frickin high school
reunion used to have jacked-up teeth get
them straightened just six-month you
start seeing results before then learn
more about candidates process and get a
complimentary 3d scan of your grill a
candid studio near you its simplest it's
the freest way to get started so are you
ready to get your teeth straight take
the first step by getting straight teeth
you can get started with a $75 off using
a code fighter at candid koat.com slash
fighter
that's candid co.com slash fighter
straighten your grill with candid use
the code fighter for $75 off candid
co.com
fighter code fighter you're wearing the
same clothing you wore yesterday haven't
been sleeping much
Papa's this my third show today three
shows a little much from a tripleheader
as a little mutt I didn't know that
that's too much too much I didn't think
we were gonna podcast today oh because
you were like we might do Thursday and
now we're doing Rogan tomorrow that's
not easy so I'm going off three hours at
two shows very hard you start to get
your bull header you've got I'm
delirious you get you know I mean you
get drained fat and that was your show
has a new business manager and they were
go over the numbers and I was literally
fall asleep over ooh uh-huh
I'll do you one better not better but I
had a seat you know a scene I'm in the
scene and Oh Oh Bryce start falling
asleep oh man
woke up got my six hours and woke up
like you know what don't need more than
that no six I'm good feeling good you
got a nice cat okay I was in the middle
of my story you're distracted oh no and
a little ornery you still got your
sunglasses show last night wait great it
did you know what really good okay how
about we're in the hallway that comments
for Santino
we got Sebastian Maniscalco right behind
us Whitney Cummings we got D'Elia Tilly
Chris Lea we got Anthony Jeselnik we got
some I mean like in the hallway in one
little clump
Let Me In D'Elia were the same shoes you
got did you plan that made him plant it
we have three or four of the same shoes
I said that Texan went dude we're off
white ducks
I'm gonna wear mine uh-huh he said so
down good he kept the plastic ring on
him and I told you I'm not even that
much of a [ __ ] boy to keep the plastic
ring on him right right that's kind of I
also changed my laces out and it changed
what I said he goes dude but they're
beasts to change a guy I know he goes
mining come with white laces I went oh
but I have a drawer in the drawer full
of all different colored laces cuz I
like to mess with laces and then this
girl was like yes are the same shoes and
Chris goes very good
you know some hot girl shoes yes have
the same shoes very good and she is but
your laces are different and I go yep
they're different and she goes oh was
that hard to change the laces and deLee
it goes shoe laces and just walks Oh
somebody's shoe laces oh my god yeah
some people just start talking huh not
much to say yeah can you do did well
they let everybody out after the main
room show they left every but they let
me out the other way so I'm hiding in
the hallway and they let me out and I'm
like that you like a politician though
everybody's like hey you know it was
kind of crazy usually let him outside no
I didn't wear this exact outfit last
night you wouldn't notice had a dark
blue shirt on last night he got off stay
night I was brushing my teeth this
morning huh
just falls on him like Kevin ate [ __ ] I
waited get water wipe it off
I'm doing an interview with uh Dominick
Cruz food-truck diary yeah and he were
telling us oh dude you have [ __ ] all of
you like [ __ ] oh oh it's toothpaste sure
it is oh my god I'm like Malika visa
toothpaste is this how is Dominick Cruz
he's great man just what what were you
guys talking about is he making a come
fishing is he coming is he making a
comeback though what do you mean
I mean he's an analyst but he's gonna
fight you he's gonna fight yeah he's it
but he had he pulled I think he had said
shoulder surgeries he almost leave me
sir but last on his shoulder yeah Wow
his body has talked trouble with that
it's like he fights once and he had
something well I mean he said of 20 year
career so it's not like well your career
but he hasn't fought a lot and he hasn't
fought a lot he passed no I don't know
six years me and him talk about so he
probably had 30 fights right yeah I
remember he he's a world champion w sign
member well chairman you have to
everything got hurt yeah so he's had
this huge career well but then he got he
got but that when the UFC got really big
yeah
that's when his injuries can be I
remember oh yeah defending I mean the
best of all time well by the way because
oh so when you say oh he yeah the long
way up well he had on laughs yeah I know
but hold on be before a 23 fights
that's a career well I'm not watching
him if he had a hold for anybody just
watch them because we were like we were
watching Dustin you gotta watch this guy
because he's got such an unorthodox way
of fighting he was one of the first guys
may be the first guy to really fight in
a way where you were like you hadn't
seen it really well yeah he talks about
that like people made fun of his
movement like everyone mimics it yes
he's like it correct yes you he said to
me once that he's got like you and chill
we're listening them talking he's like I
got the highest IQ of any fighter life
ever right he's just the best Sam he'd
be and he'd also probably be a hell of a
coach I would imagine no he is a coach
oh yes yes I didn't know that less oh
wow who's he why I mean do that that's
how I mean he was given chill pointers
when he's fighting john jones that's how
I'm so smart man yeah really really good
dude yeah man yeah but it's like you
know if you're new to fighting like God
dr. Cruz oh he's injured it's you thirty
fights before although he had a whole
career yeah was a world champion and
then it's got older that was still a
world champ either in the UFC just you
know I mean you ran up against Cody car
brand you know Cody wisdom but but you
remember he's a USA Champion correct
yeah no yeah and then have Lane injury
Domon ganja's Tom Cruise's is one of the
Great Hall Samer yeah one of the Great's
we lost your eye oh wow
long time ago 207 Wow
but then he beat you right yep defended
yep and then you know you won the
bantamweight championship of the world
by being TJ Dillashaw and then Mariah
and they lost to Cody Garr Brandt
but he talked about he fought three
times that year and how just took its
toll yeah yeah I think his back was hurt
I think he's gone he said he what he
said dude that that Cody garment fight
if it was any other fight I want to talk
it out so injured light and just beat up
cuz I fought so many times that year
three was too much
you know 15 rounds is too much in a year
yeah and he was saying he said his feet
were so [ __ ] up he had to get Botox
injections so he couldn't feel the
bottom oh come on and so he fought with
that he's like you know I I lost but
he's like I'm not making excuses don't
fight yeah yeah but Cody you look
fantastic
fight that's the last night it's three
years ago men god that bothers me that
bums me out I didn't know he was that
[ __ ] up think about that well one of
the things about like when people say my
favorite is like well he could have
fought in you have seen well hold on for
a sec or he could have played in the
pros awesome
the the even if you are able to throw
and do all that how do you play with
injuries
how do you play when you can't feel the
bottom of your feet yeah but but no one
who's been in the game that's any single
experience as that because it's not just
physical skill it's about a thousand
other things how you might manage
yourself do it no one's gonna say that
on guys who have walked the wall some
people like it not a rock not around
incredible guys here we go excuse me
yeah yeah like Mark Sanchez house fire
on me show me how to throw a football
and I'm like look here's what he goes
it's not a bad it's not a bad release I
go I'm an athlete dude I'm an athlete he
goes take it easy my senses how about
about mark yesterday goes uh I forget Oh
cuz I came out of what is today
Wednesday for your day is and yesterday
I was doing something for below the belt
on us is Monday I got it done below the
belt and I walk out in there shooting
you know that their their new football
show called forth and forever yeah with
Mark Sanchez and Adam raid that kind of
got him ready [ __ ]
Adam [ __ ] destroyed is beast in
Arizona is a beast he's so funny
so there was [ __ ] we've got mom before
yeah so they have a podcast together and
I get out I walk in there and mark goes
OH how'd you show guy your good man is
bringing on UFC fights you know some guy
that's over he's got it but we just got
a bit that's showing knowing everybody
asking about fight to go you'd be the
worst man like all the time is if their
knowledge was fine but you know yeah I
try to stay away from it yes yeah and
then there's a beating us it's Connor as
good as they fit that serious
but he's dead he we just had a long talk
it was his car as good as they say is I
go you serious is no easy I go dude we
just talked about this goes no I'm
honestly interested on it alright what
do you got
so he would talk about Connor maybe he
goes dude you don't think because you
know my favorite fight cuz he's on get
up which is my favorite sports show on
ESPN with greenberg and he goes
who's my favorite fighter that Russian
he's just such a beast we found him I
get up I watch get up everywhere and no
no wait for it and I go Russian on get
up
I know Kabhi was it on get up and he's
not Russian Technic I'm thinking I'm
like Russian is get Russian dude he's
like he just used to fight with Kimbo in
the bet in the streets of Miami oh I
stopped on it not Maz I wear this fly
don't do these this what this is this -
I don't do this here's what he went his
name's Jorge Maz would I guess that guy
go he thought he's Russian he's got it
i'ma leave now Jorge why wait hor
dude Russian Courtney Mazza at all he
goes he's not Russia oh and be haha I
literally got my car and mark mark says
wait I got my just seems like such a
smart guy but he's the bet he just don't
they don't know it isn't a fighter I
literally got my cousin all right mark
Rory mothballs Russian dude Iraq we got
a roast him let's get him on the podcast
him where you have him and Adam on
together in three weeks already
scheduled such a good guy yeah they have
a football show should do pretty well
man marks works great it's so funny how
like I when I would see him play I
always thought he's a quarterback which
means he's a six to 200 pounds
and then I go well no you're not you're
63 240 it's like just a different thing
here's the cutest cutest son man yeah so
you know he's pretty cute too
a good-looking dude yeah you know I
don't like him at all you know what I
would do to wear be able to wear a
barrette like that you go back you could
do when you're younger no I couldn't no
I just could here never good no never
had that Brennan I never grew into that
and that's what I wanted hey well who
was I telling you last night there was
like a group of like
cholo Mexicans hanging around the store
and they go hey homes are you not you
know I have my whole Mexican bit he goes
are you not Mexican I don't know you
just [ __ ] me man I know it's the sleep
back here God dude you look more max in
this I'm like
oh I don't homeboys they had the whole
the thing tied the flam little the
biggest fans are dudes like that oh yeah
the best they're always the best fans
actually those guys that take it easy
they are they're always the most
enthusiastic okay if I'm at the football
games like just punch it's like a whole
group might all [ __ ] look like rough
dues and they're the nicest guys yeah
you do you see you definitely look very
I look ethnic yeah yeah I'm shooting
today oh yeah I'm going back to work got
one little scene one little scene that
takes a long long time it's the thing
about acting takes a long time
well it's a hurry-up-and-wait game it
sure is now you got a little scene
sometimes you're just there yeah waiting
around so you got to be there called and
you have to be you have to have a
reaction shot you understand now you
have to have a reaction shot that's it
see that right there now I'm gonna need
I'm gonna leave in four hours from you
I'm gonna need four hours right now we
got a light because you're at a pool you
had a pool are we going to light the
pool cap water in it but we have to make
it look like there's a lot of light so
that right there so I'm gonna need some
light and that's how it works so you get
paid the big bucks dude it's why I get
paid the big bucks need four hours
because we're gonna have this camera
here then we have to have backdrop here
we have dude we're doing the fight
companion tomorrow that'd be fun little
whiskey I'm coming right from the saddle
that's a little whisk wish I bring some
whiskey are you gonna bring it uh
doesn't matter might be might be your
job because you're the whiskey guy I
make yeah I'll bring some Buffalo Trace
I think Rogan sponsored by a knife this
should have it right you're gonna bring
some blends well what's your whiskey
guys deserve buttons well I got if I'm
drinking we deserved be goddamn we'll
have you had Buffalo Trace
Buffalo Trace is the step below like
land what you know right before I
thought Buffalo Trace was you Buffalo
Trace
isn't that what plan that's the it's all
black yeah oh yeah Briella the Blanton's
would be there yeah so so for car
reference Buffalo Trace to be Toyota
boys would be the Lexus you drive a
Porsche RS - you should drink blends you
understand me right
don't don't scrimp on [ __ ] Wis I like
buffalo trace man
you do I do like nothing more than plans
now I like plans now my boy whiskey Pete
gave me that old-school blends why don't
we go ahead and bring that I'll bring
that I can bring that out of respect but
Eddie drinks whiskey well that's gonna
be an issue I'm not gonna that's
fantastic I love good you're crazy you
don't think I have some conspiracy to
bring up with Eddie you do Oh like legit
questions the Royal thinks I'm just
honey dick and everybody and try to be
entertaining I literally have legit
question guy on the rabbit hole maybe
okay all right I'll take the fight I'll
take the bait I love Blanton's now is
that lighting or is one darker than the
other lady one's darker Brown no one is
darker they're older there's a 30-year
Blanton's there's a 15 there's a ten I'd
like to try the 30-year old now I told
you my boy whiskey Pete Houston I think
Houston Pete's rff [ __ ] that up
whiskey Pete gave me a World War one
whiskey come on what it was from World
War want yeah you tried subtly picture
it oh dude he brought in the green room
we got [ __ ] up and I had that you
brought Pappy Van Winkle how was the
World War one whiskey well excuse me sir
World War one was in what 1978 1980 is
when it ended start to 1940 also is from
this from 1915 okay so we're talking
about a hundred and three-year-old 104
year old bottle of whiskey have you ever
tried anything that's a hundred years
well I'm not sir I've not I've not so it
tastes like I had a wine that was 52
years old that's it because I was my boy
blood from a vampire this World War one
whiskey tasted like a world one whiskey
not my my taste buds they're not there
yet they're not there yet now it tasted
like someone pissed in my mouth yeah and
I you know I didn't want to offend my
boy whiskey Pete like a dragon peed in
your mouth because it's got to be very
high proof out whiskey it amazing a
legend is like a dragon come down my
throat it was disgusting huh
and I went that's fun yeah I do know
what I'll say I went that's fun and then
the one thing I did because I remember
you said this when we're drinking wine I
went pretty earthy man pretty earthy
yeah
which made no sense when timeout whiskey
and well it's kind of like a spicy
earthy neos huh you tell you being
polite
whiskey like you know what you know what
metal will never dull well no matter if
to be a thousand years old
it will never little rather lose it will
never rust or lose its Sheen or shine
metal yeah what metal will never oh
you're saying there is a metal yeah the
copper no it won't even it won't have
nothing will grow on it the you know so
carbons so copper gets uh yeah I can get
stuff yeah it gets grease its silver now
it's in copper silver says it's a as it
was a thousand years ago this today told
yes cold cold as an element what about a
24 karat gold it'll stay it if you see
it from Egyptian times or today it all
the same luster you ever been doing into
a bank vault and seeing bars of gold
bars oh yeah that shit's mesmerized by a
great my people fought wars over it yeah
for real my agent back in the day well
the guy who owned what the agency
company when I was fighting forget his
name now hi everyone its name I don't
you knows what he's doing up but he
owned a golfer gold I went to I stayed
at his house then I went to their
offices and saw all the bars of gold
well I don't like Scrooge make that yeah
man that shit's crazy crazy gold
that's incredible a lot of Jewish names
are gold and Goldberg mm-hmm
this is a little bit of little bro
science but it's actually true so why
were the Jews primarily into diamonds
gold and things like that they were
there were brokers so if you wanted to
go even today if you want to go get buy
diamonds if you want to go to a jewelry
store a lot of times they're owned by
Orthodox Jews acidic Jews Jews in
general traditionally if you were a Jew
the reason you were in the diamond trade
in the gold trade is when when people
came to take all your [ __ ] blame you for
something or kill you you could take
your property you could take the things
of value which could sit in a one
[ __ ] bag and travel and go to the
next place let's go to the next world
that's how it was so they could just
pick up and leave in Russia in the in
the war of 1812 you read war and peace
in in in in the like this is 1812 I mean
this is when when the French invaded
Russia and they're in a war on the in
the frontlines you know there were
people the vendors that were selling you
food and you know whatever it might be
and offering services where a lot of
times choose theirs and they're known as
they were like the Jewish the Jews were
down there selling you stuff so that's
how they would survive there would be
they would they weren't allowed in
certain industries so they had this so
they like they're getting to where you
were in this country no matter where
there's a Chinese restaurant it's the
same idea you at you just figured out a
way to make a little more pretty well so
diamonds and gold still blood diamonds
where we in diamonds these days the
blood like area Liberia and Sierra Leone
any of those no no but you never know
for a Sanko for the song call and
Charles Taylor Charles Taylor said the
phone in Sanko said you have to just
make the people so miserable they have
no choice but to elect you president
so what foot is saenko and his Lords
army I think it was called or what [ __ ]
they decided hey you didn't vote for us
is it village that didn't vote for us
you vote you're sympathetic to the
government
line up we're gonna cut all your hands
off and they even cut children's hands
off great people yeah
so the whole village would have no hands
they don't have as the village fear for
sure dude how about Iran throwing some
missiles they're kind of honey dick
misses though a little bit they were it
was just the most port rattling it was
dims like it was them just trying to to
please the people who are all upset like
look we're bomb on him but it's also
like but we didn't really bomb yeah we
kind of sprinkled that's right there's
you got arrested they got a safe face
correct they got to do something they
don't want these they don't want this
nobody wants a row
nobody don't want this red and white
smoke bro any US doesn't want it either
you know nobody no no one was I think
Trump said on a Wars just an ego thing
Trump actually doesn't want yeah he
doesn't I had a Navy SEAL last night say
that he goes and he might get called up
if they go to his joke is always like
I'm not going anywhere unless we get
gonna war with her
but you guys nobody wants to war frankly
nobody not us
they don't want it nobody wants it no
one was all these innocent lives and
that for what for why [ __ ] that it's a
pissing contest these old boards are so
silly [ __ ] are so old school
you think about it yeah I'm dating but
you do and there's people sighs guys
Suleiman was like people that win are
the politicians and the Ritz like no one
no one wins man oh my my I'd love to
have been in the room to hear the
intelligence assessment of what this guy
was about to do we don't we haven't
heard anything right because that's what
Trump said in the demo Democrats are
like well let us know what the real
threats were yeah it's all it's all
classified but he must have heard
something because well first of all he
will they said he's responsible of
hundreds oh yeah in Iraq yeah show him I
was in Iraq if an Iranian who the second
most powerful guy in Iran is in Iraq
he's up teas not he's not there for
American interests just know that we
know that much so but it is scary then
we say the bombs I first saw might not
[ __ ] we're going to war man yeah but I
think those things are all calculated I
think like the 100% it's all you know
and I'm sure behind the scenes like they
don't want to go to we don't want to run
but taking this very um like sort of
said I don't want anything do it the
Middle East I want to get out of the
Middle East and Iran's the biggest
player in the Middle East yeah right and
they're there Saudi Arabia's adversary
and Iran became a lot more emboldened
when they heard that maybe they became
more active remember Iran is the sponsor
of Hezbollah in Lebanon which is
Israel's biggest sort of enemy they've
declared war on the State of Israel they
were setting up the same kinds of things
in Syria and different other parts of
the Middle East so what and that guy was
the mastermind that goddamn [ __ ]
dude oh yeah yeah yeah very smart well
they were pay he was the shadow
commander of the codes there are special
forces and all that so whatever but uh
yeah but there's a reason why Obama and
these other guys didn't pull the trigger
yeah it was always easy always were
super risky yeah little risky little
risky but I think my guess is Iran and
this guy was doing he was getting so
blatant
and it was like we can't have it
brinkmanship can't have yeah it's
brinksmanship it's it's like it's look
up the word brinksmanship it's brings
bishop's what they call like sort of
like it's it's kind of one upping it's
like it's like it's going look up look
you see little - flash
yeah a little - and I'll take a little
too big I'm gonna take like the art of
practice of pursuing a dangerous policy
to the limits of safety before stopping
especially in politics and that's what
it was
it's like this is dangerous but it might
be worth the risk because they got it
they gotta be put on notice
yeah if you don't do something with Iran
they're gonna they're gonna do whatever
they will seem get I can feel it's it's
just politics and they killed her
apparently in that car was a dude who
was commander of an Iraqi a very Pro
Iranian Iraqi force kind of like
Hezbollah yeah we can't do bad guys [ __ ]
them yeah yeah yeah but Trump's not
hawkish he's not you know expression
Hawk hawks and doves if you're a dove
you tend to favor peace if you're a hawk
of your hawkish part of the war you're
you're you favor military and that
intervention more from a duck a duck is
a different thing dude I'm a duck you're
kind of in the middle do both ducks
kinda get ducks ducks I get Swank if you
want here's what they do
I like calm but underneath hump there
you go calm feathers but you're under
behind-the-scenes you're paddling I like
a nice on the surface paddling like a
[ __ ] yeah I love it
little ducky duck duck duck bill yeah
I'll leave the doctor dude that movie
was at 1917 about World War 1 and won
all the Golden Globes and Steinman out
yeah I think about this weekend won all
the Golden Globes supposed to be so good
I'm gonna watch it
you watch that dude yeah I was in I've
been to Europe enough and I've seen the
battlefields and seen all the metal and
the cannons a few not hurts my back what
do you mean it's so depressing he's not
a [ __ ] that those weapons of that
just are made describe an LSU
cannon is this big and you're like the
World War 2 stuff and then you look out
it's really cold and you're like guys
had to fight in this cold off and die
and be injured it's like I'll do here
some
concentration camp stuff with the Nazis
and stuff like that with the Jews it is
just oh my god it's amazing humans can
do that to each other oh my god how much
your neck dude well we were just talking
what I'm sorry where were you going no
finish your thought now you don't about
you did how about Germany you just
injured me verbally I didn't your words
were violence what how about you don't
get your hunger I'll look at your finger
dude hands are dirty huh
are they they look pretty dirty okay
they are a little God they're dirty I
think I was on what was I doing I must
have been doing something don't change
tires so he explained to me yeah maybe I
was doing that no you weren't
my hands a lot of charge of tires maybe
I'm darkening you know what they idea is
when human beings think they can perfect
society it's anybody anybody here maybe
here [ __ ] talks about like perfecting
human society human beings the human
condition or even health and people have
a cure all their [ __ ] lying why are
you looking at my really so dirty
no no I just know you throwing on my
face do you look like the head I was I
was reading a newspaper no you look like
you're a mining yeah I do
oh maybe no no oh your Tesla falling
apart huh the ink for the steering wheel
again no you see II on I must dancing no
stop Shh not a good dancer no stock the
stock is four hundred and forty dollars
a share the high stock of any like car
some Tesla yeah my friend his there a
Tesla guy who works a test that goes buy
stock it was 120 bucks here's why he
goes I'm just telling you dude I'm
looking at all the orders it's gonna be
crazy
he's not a good dancer but he's awesome
you never can be that smart and gonna be
a good dad can't happen oh yeah you see
this mom she's hot yeah she was a model
severe-looking later dude I love I love
you I love looking at Elon Musk before
he was rich god that's is the Fox most
show mark Wow oh yeah
oh yeah she was no joke was she rich I
believe dude his mom is that kill us
dude I would [ __ ] you on must mom she
looks like a real-life Cruella developed
I was just thinking her hair's dope yeah
she is a stone-cold yeah all straight-up
monologues and I love it was she a
grandma model yeah she an older model I
love a woman at that age who takes it
that good care of herself look at the
[ __ ] detail Wow that's all there's
grandma models yeah I thought once
JCPenney shut down years old
covergirl contract good firm Wow huh I
need you to appreciate that
did you appreciate her whilst you get
the body on mrs. MA this is when she was
younger miss musk she was crushing it
Mei musk crystal on it yeah she was
probably killing Elon Musk mom Mei musk
huh Mei musk on me dude laughing there
and her hair is for what a fantastic
look still keeps it together dude I'm
not into the grandma porn but this is
kind of getting fueling some emotions am
i dead I don't need you to be this look
you want some look at that dude well
that one bothers human tonight so it's
like a girl knife right there oh she's
getting ready to go to Mars
get your body I like my hair thanks dude
that'd be tough you growing up your
mom's just a [ __ ] model yeah
dude how about and I mean he grew up you
know he's obviously a [ __ ] genius
yeah see he's on the perspec
is well straight he might just be worked
on a different wavelength that we just
were like oh he's weird or he's just so
much hardness mom look dude she aged way
better she was hotter than that she's
hot when she's older she's hot then to
look at her now though something happen
she got dark like it was a darkness with
her dude it's and I'm sure you know if
when your mom's a superhot model that's
different but how about Tom Hanks son I
sent you that video yeah oh we have that
for current event
if your dad is force Gump you know how
hard the wind is for you one of the
greatest fir has to authorize you were
with you with them I was talking all I I
saw I saw that video
it was in my popular page I click on I'm
like why the [ __ ] he talking like this
I'm being addicted as Instagram ever
since he's a white I was I do he's a
white rapper I never looked into it
dude this is fantastic you and your dad
is [ __ ] captain Phillips it is a tough
go at life man he's a musician yeah he's
a rapper always a rap yeah you put yeah
comin a chapter now speaking patois are
my roommates from Jamaica spoke that way
and you couldn't understand a word but
did you have roommates from Jamaica mod
my roommates from Jamaica because that's
how it wasn't in college and out are
what college a miracle Corrigan
University bobsled team and then when
they when they talk you couldn't
understand a word they were saying but
now it was patois but he keeps doing it
boy like going like this one channel I
know that's good too because the youth
then we're at the Kingston they wake up
this month you see the pain tunnel
internet gone mad respek you don't know
this one far but I got her it's tough
dude it's tough when your dad that make
you all embarrassed the most advanced
Brian because your dad's come hey the
one son is an actor but you know yeah I
don't wanna make fun of the guy cuz I
you know I don't know him he might be a
great guy it may be this is an ass I
don't know but what I do know for some
of these kids who are their parents are
insane superstars it's it's tough on the
kid man it's very tough on the kid go to
some is there any videos hit okay
go to youtube or I go to YouTube I'm
sure he's rapping on YouTube can we see
some ones cuz he said he posted a songs
this whole thing about like this cool to
be black basically like he explained it
in this it's ham though he explained him
being black and what he was doing with
the Jamaican accent so it's all about
history making accent but has to be yeah
rap please oh here we go do it better
well just came out seven years ago there
another one give me a variety of it man
this is making my day okay I'm already
in no I don't know what it is this is
his this is his do you think yes his dad
doing say I'm me on his dad's like no
wait his name is his name is Chet haze
then what is Brian Chet haze so it's all
black and white guy 2012 so cast away
just came out see like oh what's it dad
dammit what up give me another one that
let's not judge them based off that
seven years ago
oh there's one here's my thing again I
don't make funny guy huh it might be a
great imagine if this was your son
button I know I know you're not you're
not five six eight years you're playing
a character you know it so it's the top
I don't know if he has any recent music
no he does he cuz used he's just doing
the Jamaican accent that he just dropped
the new one year ago it's performed live
that's live perfect Chin's rank his
voice
COO stick - oh here we go models but
I'll say he might be happy as [ __ ] and
just loves to make music it's just guys
trying to get laid
no no no it's guys just lost really like
dude your dad's Forrest Gump Majesty
wants to be legitimate cocaine and
marijuana you don't know anything about
that though right on the corner with
guns
you'd imagine Tom Hanks in the crowd
right now like all right that's that's
what that's what I mean is like give me
another one fat you didn't really earn
that like in a way like like you're
talking about being on the corner right
ah but why not talk glad I'm not the
only one I always get so embarrassed I
get so embarrassed by this but all the
rock and roll guys were copying the
blues black blues from England they were
they were doing the same thing but yeah
but damn oh there this is Venice though
same guys this is an actual video
instead of live that guy's really he's
busy with himself any he's my age too so
yeah he's not young he's not young
there's a lot going on this is like bad
Barbie she's at she's Italian and Jewish
you know that there's no black in her
chillin on the corner with cocaine and
marijuana Tom makes like white I was in
big dude hey this is what happens bro
does it gonna let me send kids down
there so I like about him though where
I'm not gonna go dude on the terrible
and they're probably really nice guy
they go to the other one goes other
songs a nice guy that was there do you
see it was that alone is recommended
they're not bad no I'd like I don't
wanna be too mean - it's right there
there were groups called ft RZ Oh ninja
rap it City rapping they wanted say
everybody wants to be
everybody wants to be legitimate
everybody wants to be taken seriously
sometimes it's a little bit of a clumsy
actor he's a good-looking dude right
counter yeah what is he yeah that's in
the room let me hear him talk all right
go back for a second he's a good-looking
dude it's just all this is a little
entertaining my homey just show me this
beat
oh yeah rewind out here and say homie do
you think Tom Hanks like what homie are
you referring to
dude I'm sorry from that early night it
sounds exist like that yeah anyways see
oh go to live Central Michigan let me
see how that they liked it
I'm coin deep into Chet haze I get so
tight it's so tough man it's so tough
it's [ __ ] tough man when your dad's
Tom Hanks dude and you're trying to
navigate your way my razor is his mom
Rita yeah I know that's his actual real
world yeah we uh damn I forgot last name
but she's an actress too right yeah yeah
we're ready to Wilson premises
generation you grew up loving black
musicians just like usually laughing I
don't it is black though it's black
culture it's like is it came out of no I
know he's right his thing it's I I don't
know I don't know it's from left field
he grew up in you know Brentwood he
wants to be yeah he's a really black he
wants he wants to be faintly he wants to
find his path and he's like yeah it's so
different than some some I know you know
that are these gurus these life's just
not terribly authentic it's a tough one
well he's law there's lost man they
don't know they don't have luck he's
he's doing music yeah he's doing
something like he's working yeah yeah
out there yeah I know you was an addict
for a long time
yeah your dad is Forrest Gump dude
you're gonna do some drugs shadow is so
deep it's so it's that I would say the
way to get out of it is become a doctor
or get out of the business don't try to
be in show business but you can't say
that when you ever say this what you
want hear him talk about why he did the
Jamaican accent sure yeah please let's
just I can't get enough of
Irma's some about him check this out one
two one two are enough enough all right
look never in a million years when I
thought that me just goofing around on
the river except the hippos so much
attention man it's been crazy and one
thing I'm not joking about is my love
and appreciation for Jamaica the
Jamaican culture that has been
incredible all the love that I've been
getting from Jamaica has been really
incredible it touched me deeply in my
heart so thank you guys so much in my I
just want to say thank you you know it's
all into oh there's his new song click
on the soundcloud link for me let's just
hear his current song before we go to
Harlem again I like there's something
about a night I'm interested in is he in
making rapping I don't know I like him
already
seems like this he's doing it for ya too
much I like him yeah see something right
there's something you like seems like a
nice guy just kind of doing what he
wants to do how good nice guy his dad I
can't upset his daddy's Tom Hanks it's
[ __ ] I'm sure he you might want to
dish the other gather a blessing and a
curse
[Applause]
his partner on the line up pretty good
[Music]
let's go son should we write this yes
[Music]
can't hide behind that skirt I know
you're hurt
it's alright here's the thing you know
what's interesting is your dad may be
one of those famous actors of all time
and it doesn't help you one bit in the
music business like you are the habit of
you don't you know so maybe he has it I
don't know do you guys know I don't know
if he has it I mean spin disease isn't
terrible you make things not terrible
I'd be a lot worse yeah but the solder
the song the lyrics and stuff jeez
they're just it's like oh it's like it's
just like kitty yeah it's not yeah cuz
how old is he oh now here's the thing
the guy back there I'll do - I can't I
can't be nice today like he just started
on this team there's a lot of work there
now they said there's a bad man account
around there's a whole situation of his
long look him up I need to know about
Chet Hanks's alright yeah 29 pretty
young son he might have been 10 weeks
big night but Twitter posted a video
okay how do we look for it
Chet Hanks so so he's the youngest one
yeah is there any is there any video of
Tom Hanks thought about his son you want
to know how I feel also I've never said
this really probably publicly never
cared for Tom Hanks is an actor don't
give a [ __ ] about him oh interested like
very nice guy but never I never would go
to a movie because he's in it never I
love them I mean love never would if you
can there you go don't care walk right
there yeah yeah sure there are factors
that would have done a better job yeah
didn't think dad didn't never really
thought he was a great actor
you want me a refill your haterade over
there I know it's terrible I just have
always like I just have never never
never got it I never got Brad Pitt
either how about that
never got Brad or not as well I'm
telling Brad Pitt Fight Club yeah good
one that's the one movie
7/7 is good Hollywood a lot of people
could have done that but somehow I
didn't see it
that's it but no nothing doesn't do it
doesn't do it for me as an actor okay
all right uh I'm never critical but that
guy what's his name
Oh needs his name is drew gotta get his
real name now this is true that's right
now don't go too hard on him don't
releases no that's all good I mean it's
on his Instagram I'm not going bad on
these guys I'm not trying to go bad on
them I'm really not well you did know
just figure it out man it's just a lot
of there's a lot of accoutrement there's
a lot of things oh I see what's Emily
with that much work going on I know look
here's my thing though I don't know if
that's if he likes if this is what they
like I don't get that Elliot is pretty
sick I would never get that but that
yeah I can appreciate it
listen if this what you like I don't
give up it's so you're happy doing I
don't your phone that's not what I'm
talking about I'm saying it's a lot
going on there yeah I'm dissing hey prep
is Jorge's I can't be serious but yeah
what don't you like about Brad Pitt I
don't know he's that guy don't dislike
Brad Pitt I just I would believe it or
not never go to a movie if they're in
the movies great but I would never go to
a movie because they were in it I would
go to a movie because of Danny Lewis
Chris Christian Bale there's certain
people I go to a movie for Willem Dafoe
the different kinds of people that I
love and those two never did it for me
it's like the police they might be a
grab grab and never like them know
certain things like that they just don't
but you have a bit personal
it might be just more of a personal
frequency I don't I don't know doesn't
move me because you're an actor
especially Tom Hanks there's a lot of
actors like I just don't believe Tom
Hanks I always saw Tom Hanks I never saw
ice never saw him acting
very well I thought it's great in
Philadelphia yeah yeah you have to go
anyway that's good but if you had seen
him if you had seen see you see Tom
Hanks in Philadelphia if you had seen an
actor like day-lewis or anybody like
that or for that matter Shia LaBeouf I
guarantee those guys would have been
they would have done a better job they
would have done something that would
have brought you to your knees and Tom
Hanks in that movie didn't I saw him who
I thought I had in my head and I was not
forced Gump
who would do a better job before a
fantastic job would have you might have
been the best for that
yeah sometimes so this guy's you you do
a role and it's an natural yeah he was
great then I go Brian saying huh like
cuz he he that's his world he's always
looking at lemmings in first company was
as good as it that that was Tom's role
but there are a lot of roles that other
people would have done a much better job
in there you go happening I believe I
like those guys I think they're great
too but I don't know what it's like to
be an actor it's more of a personal it's
this is more of a person ace like you
like Taylor Swift right yeah I don't
think she's amazing shift I think just
made incredible artist though I don't
think see I don't mean she's good I
don't think she's an incredible artist I
think she's very good for her age and
beautiful thank you do you think Kanye
West is I was a spot I respect how good
he is but that's not my world you hate
them what they're saying is our judged
but here's why I like Kanye West which
is really interesting some artists I
listen to their song and it's like
catching a gos is good and then the
fourth time I listen to it I don't want
to listen to it anymore I went down the
rabbit hole with Kanye West cuz I didn't
know what the [ __ ] deal was right and
I listened to everything he's ever done
all his collaborations don't on the 10
no I did I'm the town the tenth listen
on the tenth listen it it's just as good
or better sometimes whatever that done
it guide is doing with some of those
classic songs now there's a new album
but yeah I didn't hear I had all the
ridges but yeah I didn't hear that but
is the [ __ ] that got him to the dance is
collaborations with jay-z and all these
people on I was Billy ocean where the
[ __ ]
some of those songs are really good
notion Frankish I did listen to every
single album like every one more than
one I got I downloaded everything but
like there's something it was really
interesting because I'll listen to it
now and I go that's a go yeah he's
all-time great yeah yeah [ __ ] now
he's weird whatever right what got him
to the dance is the best special had the
best yeah please tell me that he found
so many people that you look at the list
of people that he'd like who's the
player I John Legend found him in a
hotel yeah John doesn't acknowledge that
too much anymore because Kanye's so anti
like Trump and like you know and I'm
sorry because Kanye is like from where
Trump pro-trump they kind of don't [ __ ]
with him I like dude I mean he would
have got to skip it you know I think he
would have made it maybe there's so many
talented musician many there's so many
yeah but kinda put him on so it's like
come on dude that's a huge I can
separate politics like let's say you
were super pro Trump I'm not crazy
dramedy I wouldn't give a [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] I can separate the two so
long as you're not like racists or
something like that a little race up
sometimes it's funny
louis c.k the racist one pizza and i
walk in four black women are making my
pizza
all right maybe there's another one now
the way that's a great job yeah what
else we got
Kermit's yeah sure man all right okay
this was submitted by Zak duro I think
that's how you say his last night um but
a while back there was a situation where
Logan Paul was asked who he would want
to fight next and he threw out Antonio
Browns name recently Antonio Brown
responded and said that he'd be down to
fight Logan Paul in a boxing match and
Logan Paul said that he would drop him
faster than the Patriots so now they
want to do a box honey I've got a why I
mean I don't know I'm telling you Brown
would have to train for a while but I
mean that's a very different
odd shark right there I don't think
local Paul's ever bought an athlete like
that what are you what are your thoughts
on that Brenda job you just know how
much of a freak athlete Antonio Brown
please to anybody please give us him I
love this [ __ ] I love this so please
give us some some of your thoughts on
this cuz Antonio Brown I don't think
Logan Paul even understands how fast and
tell me how Browns hands are what kind
of an athlete is what do you have to do
to get Intel you're brown to stop will
you talking about point
oooo one of all football players make it
to the NFL level point
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh one are all
pros then point oh one our [ __ ] Hall
of Famers that'd be Antonio Brown so
it's just different you have you seen
like a lean forward flip yeah it's just
aliens 510 185 look at Paul 62 190 look
was a big kid but yeah and Tonio Brown I
would imagine if he starts this is where
you're getting in a weird world like you
know blowin in Paul's a buddy of mine I
like Logan Paul like what do you
represent stuff like that he's made a
career for himself but this is where the
lines get a little blurred here you know
yeah just when you fight when we start
another youtuber that makes sense you're
frightened not like an amateur fighter
alright whatever but when you start call
it like real real athletes you know it
gets a little funky yeah it's fun to
talked about yeah you know it you know
it'd probably get views and Tony around
just he's still very young still got
speed it's give him some just give him
some training how long's he get to train
for I don't know real this is listen
this one never happened yeah you're
taking it too serious well composite
jacked [ __ ] though he's
definitely jacked you see you ever seen
that tell you brown now now one of them
is a youtuber we love him and then one
led the NFL and catches the NFL because
he got some speed though oh there is
yeah yeah yeah good one where he's
flexing there you go yeah now one is
factually crazy yet every NFL team is
trying to snow
for those are they still is he gonna
play again I don't know
is he being is he being the saint Prada
meant for workout oh they did yep I
don't think they sign them really and
they and they lost because of it
damn that's super jacked yeah he that's
why the only house yeah he's a thick boy
he's probably got some help that's
that's a big kiss that'll nipples on him
they're like one yeah yeah one bigger do
you wrestle in college do you tell me
that high school high school junior
college mm-hmm cuz they meet he's making
millions doing YouTube yes I said a tits
on him huh yeah he's big kid good guy
man excellent yes so a 20 year old woman
was on her way back from Australia to
Manchester and she was very drunk when
she got on this flight so much so that
she decided to continue the party
throughout the flight she continuously
got drunk and started talking to people
around her and asking guys like oh do
you want to join me in the bathroom in
join the mile-high for six months for
that I'm in because my gate inches give
it up that wasn't you see me this
Saturday Wilbur boss she's hot a smock
dude she was smoke sure that wasn't the
problem though the problem was that she
saw around her asked her to keep it down
and then the flight attendant said ma'am
we can't serve you any more alcohol she
got really angry and started to just
lose her [ __ ] she was biting people she
was shaking and it took six people to
finally I'm really not actually not a
good drunk she's a strappy not a good
drunk she's a little contrite there
she's not in a good mood
she's how dgo bad she bad girl she's
jadon girl mad daddy she's sorry great
flyer miles should be somebody keep her
on a straight oh you need you need wings
want your little wings you want some
nuts with your wings nuts
vital we should define a little by let
me get my let me get my wrist guard on
in there
bow down on my belt you just reach
10,000 feet loop Wi-Fi in your mouth why
all right let's see the next kind of man
I gotta go back to work oh no oh no you
were just do a couple real quick you
gotta go back right now right what they
say on the last shot of yours summit
page say [ __ ] you okay um I can't get
any rest ma'am go home my son's gonna
wrestle the [ __ ] out of them it's fun
though you've gotten look at you and
tell you to square up you just yeah like
this oh my god dude it's fun yeah you're
never gonna win buddy yes I see Joe
Lambert's finger [ __ ] yeah pretty gross
they just probably finished the game too
he came back in wrap it up came back in
finishes his a lot of time in the game
check this out
oh how bad is that I'm sure they just
snapped it back in so it did pop back in
but it's still lame I think a ligament
damage so he might be I'll be all right
don't you know I don't know look at that
yeah that's not having my pink you do
did yeah it footballer stands on the
territory huh first day at sea football
camp when I was [ __ ] in sixth grade or
fifth grade my very first day running
out route and [ __ ] Johnny rocket
through the goddamn ball so hard I turn
the ball hits like this first day
no parents paid $400 for he goes goddamn
camp first day he boom oh no how old
were you I don't know fifth grade with
brain oh my god flip III poppy you not
Papa did so you know let's play
quarterback
I look at pro football players hands a
lot sighs they always washed up I mean
cuz you're hitting your hand hands hips
of sharks noses
scars all over uh the rough what a
problem that's not you good at time do
more what's up let's do another one
one more meet best one okay what's too
late now but JJ Watt his girlfriend's a
professional soccer player so she's
gonna get traded to a different team
she's so cute she's very cute she's cute
and she is from Houston and a Houston
local news station wrote that Houston -
betrayed - JJ Watts fiancée to Chicago
so they didn't say her name they
considered her JJ and then JJ Watt was
pissed off about it so the deadline is
trash Kalai oh I for sure get a water
named Goliath high which is her name by
the way since you didn't bother to
mention it you stupid [ __ ] is
incredible the idea of that is
incredible entirely on her own merit and
be treated as such be better than said
that's a Hawaiian name yeah she's a
badass and she liked that huh he wrote
that so her she did yeah now let me see
some more pictures of her she's a door
was your talk yeah
she is I just want to say thank you
thank you to the entire dash
organization for drafting me and giving
me the opportunity to play professional
check out the brows on Becky mates
I love you guys so much so yeah damn ray
shifts a little awful I've seen Adam
raise eyebrows yeah thank you to all the
Houston - fans you guys have been so
what's how much you just think some
instead of teeth under what else is that
all we got she Abdullah I'll go to AIDS
older in zebra way why does why would he
date a big girl bro I don't know I feel
as he needs him like no I knew his
spinner it's bad yeah all right give me
tiny dude I bet she's not that time he's
just huge you want to see sure Kohli I
don't know what position she plays so
she's just little then click on
something yeah oh oh it's adorable she
is a jjt oh yeah I wonder if she plays
with my boy Matt Matt's his girls Sophia
it's very cute
she's super cute huh good for him
sticking up for his girl yeah
now how tall JJ I don't know but yes ten
pounds I know that some crazy it was
such a freak athlete he just came back
six five five Oh what is that Jim why
were you looking at that look member the
human Ken doll or the rig while it is
you've heard watched he must have been a
male he must unbox hell yeah I got that
Barbie we finally came out as
transgender now he feels like he's a
woman so what's he look like
well that was in before and that's him
now so this is the oh this is her
Instagram
that's right other pictures I see the
body on this um don't that don't get
Brennan on too much plans because he'll
make some decisions here he didn't want
to know with that fin I'll get a call I
get a call right I gotta talk to you
know that face there's not enough
buttons in the world like you that's
your right or what that look at that
hold on what an absolute mess what an
absolute hey click on Chloe con that's
probably let me see need to catch up now
is that another is that a trance no
who's that they have that face that same
face it looks like it's dude scroll up
its like roll out Oh sculptor no scroll
up to her probably see the tits [ __ ] you
how's the vibes only is that only fans I
had oh is that a Tran I don't want that
Tran that's a girl
no that's a goal you'll see the video if
you could please
hey either way I'm in the face dog hey
Google chin we're weak on a thumbs up
and thumbs down
girl or boy girl or boy I'm saying girl
with major head trauma um I'm going used
to be a boy oh that's an hour done Oh
goat pronouns we just thrown out the
hearse hers and she British by the way
there's some problems there huh she's
pretty hot though right I'd say no no
she's just really huh she just has that
worked on her face
I think she's delicious wait that's how
she used to look see it's less work yeah
she was cute oh yeah that's less work
all right well that's why she's an
absolute disaster oh [ __ ] go the ass
what chin yo that one
what were you saying though Brian
disaster
I say masterpiece yeah I don't know if
you're into it it's a fun it's like into
being into cars
that talk hold on let me go to her where
go back to the ass shot
mmm cuz she's posting an ass shot and
she's trying to say something seriously
no she's all natural a couple of months
ago in a moment of sandman credibly
wrote stupid things about my hubby and
attempt to stop us going back to each
other during a brief but very intense
fight I never write about my family
online only did it because I truly
believed we were done we couldn't last
really a day without each other and we
were back to perfect couple of days
later got a new smoker place together
etc actually even higher level than
before even though I didn't want to give
social media another episode in my
private life for people to get the
popcorn out I didn't want people to
think I was laughing this is fantastic
and as we move into a new year I want
2020 with peace and a true heart so I
want everyone to know I'm sorry for
causing such commotion even though at
the time I really didn't deserve what
happened bi priests we should never talk
bad about you're right dad when you're
right you're right
very intensively drawn we've had a
fabulous relationship hard and it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter I don't
agree with everything he says it doesn't
matter we moved into day one yeah she's
great I don't agree with everything he
says we are two complete different she
wants moving to 2020 with a clear mind
and heart okay hey what did she say
you think she's take it down see if
chief son last post Jen then will get
bright out of here a couple months ago
in a moment of insanity every good oh I
think she might have wrote whatever it
is she's apologizing for on these photos
and then went back and edited the
caption so it's an apology and stuff
well if she's like that's why I suck
Greg's dick bah blah blah oh and then
race these huh
she a little tomcat I'm gay dude real
lips Xmas is my favorite day of the year
yeah she looks kind of like normal love
you saw in person none of mine she's
probably ethnically Pakistani I think
she's conness usually a Pakistani name
and I think Muslim you look sort of
bulgy well that's a situation she was
you man I think she though I don't know
I don't know let's say about this person
yeah I mean she's not doing so well I
would imagine god I wish I knew what
drama she spilled so because got a
popcorn out you check it that oh wait
thank you let me see that we see these
girls seem like they're really smart can
I see her whoa check out this hiss
that's you check out this one my life
those like wait she's not vain at all
she seems very happy and well put
together mm-hmm
it's just too much wow wow oh
underboob that is just amazing to me
she's living life though you know she's
gonna work out it's gonna work out I
think it's gonna really and and well oh
that's her man I don't know he's looking
at all a stranger would you ask a
stranger take a pic for you so I was in
the airport earlier right and I saw two
guys taking pics of each other so I
asked them would you take pics for me to
my joy he took about 50 the slight
compromise that his pal jumped in about
48 of them MI right so at this stage I'm
like hell I'm as well post one of us
haha yep
all right well on that note guys come
see me in Nashville this weekend sold
out I believe except for we have some
tickets for the Early Show
Janey's we got Cleveland hilarities
January 30 31 February 1 we got West
Palm Beach new date it's Valentine's Day
Feb 14 15 Jack set yeah dude you know
west palm strum plan dude west palm he
runs that City and Connecticut Foxwoods
this Friday Boston Wilbur theater
Saturday next week for Valentine's Day
no that's not Valentine's Day I don't
know why I'm working Sunday then I think
it's a holiday
either way next week San Jose Improv
Friday Saturday Sunday then the week
after that I'm in Charlotte comedy zone
January 23rd to 25th then I NJ in Ohio
Columbus Ohio at the funny bone in
Columbus Ohio January 31st through
February 1st get your tickets now to fat
K calm dude Valentine's Day I'm an
Ontario improv California February 13th
through 15th great grand wonderful jfl
Just for Laughs comedy festival
Vancouver One Show vogue theatre that's
almost sold out t pack a calm Bryan
anything else I'd say buddy boy just a
fun kid we're out yeah